hello everybody my name is welcome what
it's been a while my name is markiplier
I'm finally back in LA and I'm back to
recording and I'm back to not being
unbelievably incredibly busy and I have
lots to talk about in my time in Austin
but I will save that for a Monday vlog
which I'm gonna do but that's not why
you're here you're here for the scare
games you're here for scares like to
start off this three scare games with a
game called hollow cries chapter one
won't let go Chapter two but what if
Chapter three don't leave me
chapter four rock me to sleep okay
interesting I didn't know there are this
many chapters
Alyssia one goes tell me about what
happened that night little one okay I'll
tell you all about oh [ __ ]
I was on the floor with my big baby's
first Ouija board oh yeah oh unlock more
questions as you progressed who gave a
baby Ouija bellari I just have to I'm
reeling from this concept and also why
is a baby asking how did you da baby I
saw baby crib there this is a baby right
this is a baby asking the spirits from
the beyond
why did you how did you die Oh L was
that Oh L o V
Liuba la la ville lair Lord Lord let
love love I get it that's very cool
yes okay good
where are you now H Oh hope oh um
humming him home okay alright so your
this is your home is that what you're
saying
alright okay I'm just a baby oh I'm
amazed that I can form sentences let
alone read letters so this is incredible
I must stand up now oh oh [ __ ] okay well
yeah this uh this game might be no joke
this might be one of those no joke games
Oh Prezi to sleep I don't think I'm
gonna oh [ __ ] bear go hello is someone
there
is someone there oh [ __ ]
left window when you hear the window
open use your flat wait wait a minute
the cries when the baby cries run over
to soothe the baby oh not the baby
oh okay left window flashlight
flashlight Oh sick
why stay calm oh okay
flashlight don't all right that's good
window window anxiety
ah baby no cry
hey baby hey baby hush I don't know why
is this my job
Isis where's my job alright whatever
good baby good good job baby good hey
come on now come on what are you doing
but close my eyes for a little bitter oh
[ __ ] whoa whoa then well wait a minute
wait a second okay you know how come
stress I'm dealing with here
you think you got a bad you monsters
gonna eat you up all right
anyway can you hush your white what is
with this monster growl baby I need to
rest my head my weary
Wow damn you baby
I hate me oh sure that's not that's
that's the opposite of what you might
call good I hate being a six-year-old
new father Oh child rearing is so
stressful what is this my job
alright good welcome more good morning
I'm lame I asked Abed what am I waiting
for how long is it supposed to go for
hello
I guess we're fine sure just gonna
snooze my way to snooze town we snobby
stuff oh don't worry mom and dad maybe I
am taking care of the baby as is my job
very clearly as is very clearly my job I
am gonna die cuz my heart is gonna
explode alright if I don't get some
goddamn sleep here I don't know what I'm
gonna do I haven't even had my coffee
that's tough being a kindergartner and
then 2090 alright sure no all good MA
all good here you can trust me
you can trust little old me I'm so good
at raising babies alright whatever
Oh what what what's happening huh I
guess I won or I'm dead it's really
either/or at this point oh oh how you
doing baby hey baby hey baby baby baby
are you in that [ __ ] mom risky to move
on oh she I'm gonna transcend into the
spiritual plane
it's time for me to move on my business
is finished here all right I guess
new chapter unlocked great you know
that's real cool I think all right but
what if if only I knew the question the
answer to what if but what if but what
if I what if all right let's try this
what what what there's a hidden pup toy
at the end of each level not very hidden
no what did you hope to find
I don't know ghosts my afraid no ghosts
okay all right ug time boy oh boy oh boy
are you are you bad you bad is there
anyone there
yes are you bad oh you bet yes is it
still yes sir just you thinking about
are you thinking about it you bet are
you alone
also goodbye wait why
I don't make no sense goodbye are you
alone also goodbye you know as I'm
asking these I expect you guys to answer
these questions in the comments are you
bad come on Oh
wombo whoa holy on Tuesdays why okay are
you bad
why okay I will see you around it was
good talking to you ghost friend of mine
I'm just gonna lay my head to rest you
know sleep uh-huh Lee hello is someone
there is it my wardrobe when you hear
the Wardrobe up and use your flash
ah are we back my whole recording
computer crash so I don't know where
that file left off but I don't even know
if it's there I might be starting
completely from over but I died it
happened like this I was playing I
noticed it crashed over there and then I
was like oh [ __ ] I got to fix that and
then I got stumped scared right at that
moment when I turned away it was like
optimal jumps carriage nests but you
guys didn't see it well I'm gonna go
away this time now you guys are just
gonna sit here and
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
hey I'm back what'd I miss
oh no you're dead Oh guys I told you I
left you in charge of this what do you
what did we talk about okay all right
even that I have no idea what's recorded
in this fine and what's not recorded I'm
gonna go ahead and back out of this one
and I'm gonna start up the next game
we're gonna move on boo game called all
happy now this game is it might be a
joke in but sometimes joke aims or the
best honey I forgot my purse
in the graveyard today do you mind if
you stop by after work and pick it up
for me okay thank you bye I forgot my
purse in the graveyard
your purse in the graveyard you put I
was why would you be in a situation
where you would go to the graveyard and
be able to even leave your purse what
were you doing in that graveyard setting
it down to dig up a body is this where
the graveyard is Oh looks like I need a
key of course I don't belong here all
right
oh boy this doesn't look like a
graveyard book I didn't scare me I'm
unscareable hello you sudden door
bastards all right now if I were a
person a graveyard where would I be here
hello anybody oh okay big clue all right
anybody there oh ah the naughty chair in
the closet
don't mind me barging are the anxiety of
my actions that I realized I was
bursting into someone's private abode it
got to me there for a second but I'm
over it
oh you two have a naughty chair with a
naughty bucket or anyway hello Oh uh-huh
get more naughty chairs with two naughty
buckets ah a ceremonial banana stand
hey Corky bull must be the church pastor
I think that's what they call them
years since I've been in a church so I
think that's how it's gonna be huh is
that right tall poppy I'm gonna show you
something about hairy legs hey
everything seems fine sorry I apologize
to the nun nuns in the church Master
we're doing not the organ music I
usually get when I walk into a church
and of a weird somber echo into the arse
of damnation happening but cool sure
whatever
hey whoa whoa okay goodbye whoa okay go
oh no oh no gonna be like that is it it
is a prank game Oh
I'm sorry what number one where is that
and is that moving whatever good morning
father I have sinned or by the time you
read this I will have sinned is that the
proper way to use the word sinned
anywheres there's a visitor here tonight
I plan on having a little fun no we all
know my touch kills
okay I'm gonna dismember this individual
it'll be fun well at least for me freak
out or anything I and if you're lucky
you can eat the body lots of good meat
on this one don't let it go to waste
hey I appreciate the compliment by
please don't
oh don't just look at yours okay all
right cool ah I love my scare meter my
scare amadeur hey whoa Oh got it
nailed it okay anyway goodbye
very smooth delicious Oh tastic even
anyway I got the key is to go over here
this is a long way to the grater okay
Spooky's House of jump-scares you've
calmed down there oh wait uh I mean I
guess this isn't too out of place for an
old church but for a LOD guy admit scram
get back here what oh yeah okay
but then I guess I got our run uh-huh
I'm not gonna catch you no you're not oh
[Music]
hey are you actually a thing hey wait
all papi long papi big papi
ooh it's one do you want to be called I
got oh wow whoa whoa whoa easy easy easy
I got a [ __ ] eat [ __ ] oh I died
apparently oh I died
[Music]
I think I got got billy game alright
wait no oh god where am i oh okay my
purse in the Greek name do you mind if
you stop by after work and pick it up
for me hey it worked
I'm at the last checkpoint I don't know
what I got is some kind of blue oh
that's cool I guess I got I got blue I
don't know where all poppy is but I got
blue oh wow how did my wife get all the
way through your to the graveyard I
think I could have hopped a fence or
something
Here I am I don't know if the game is
like permanently broken or something but
there is think I might have broke the
game pretty sure I broke this incredibly
well-crafted and finely tuned game
f-first pepperonis oh hey is that my
wife's purse okay read this first to
read they made it to the Graveyard I
want to know how many other Knightly
visitors I've buried air you hurt your
left is a man named Jesse if I can touch
you alright I know you wanna take your
limp put them in fun hard place to read
can I have a alright well nothing's
happening I think I broke it
I'm pretty sure I broke this day I
didn't break it god damn you you sack of
[ __ ] alright okay well I got my wife's
purse so I guess I'm just gonna Posey on
back down
I don't know how you're able to do
teleportation powers tall poppy butter
you cut that out you cut that nonsense
out right now you you scoundrel you
scamp oh can i oh it's a gate I'm free
I'm free I'm runnin I'm runnin I'm
runnin go I made it
did I make it hey I made it oh I did it
I did it guys you're proud of me all
those years of playing horror games
really fine-tuned my incredible
expertise of this stuff hey can I can i
skadoodle on to next we're gonna play a
game that's art by post unfortunately
I'm a mime how signed in well I didn't
expect to be so frame slip I'm err back
room medium
[Music]
the madness of one rhythm
- endless like the noise of floors
androids at maximum pompous and
approximately 600
subscribe to be sick
to be trapped
god save you if you hear something
button around me I buy because it sure
oskol has helped you
oh okay all right so this is apparently
a horror game sometimes they're behind
quiet
it supposed to be a horror game that's
not based in darkness Oh
oh my oh my oh my oh my me oh my
okay so there's something in here with
me I don't know how I got here I don't
know what I meant by noclipping
could I know clip my way through life
oh okay great okay all right um I'm sure
what that's what what am I supposed to
do am I supposed to not look at him
that's the idea I think that's the idea
don't look at it don't look e at him
okay I'm not gonna look I'm gonna look
around I'm gonna look at looking at him
not gonna look looking looking for me oh
look I know
oh my so I might understand that this
thing is just gonna pop in out of
nowhere because it hears me imma I'm us
prising Li loud individual it is
disconcerting I gotta admit it's weird
being in a brightly lit environment and
knowing something lurking out there that
is that is definitely weird but
feel like there should be something more
here I feel like it should do something
more to me then okay um it is the kind
of thing that slowly drives you crazy
cuz there's this nothing but noise
everywhere the sake of noise if you were
to actually stuck you'd go crazy in like
thirty minutes you'd go insane because
this is just digging into my brain I
feel like I'm being programmed with like
some subliminal messages here well
that's not good 30 seconds well you know
I might die from that or I'm gonna die
for whatever's gonna look at me
everything same everything exactly this
time there's no way to know or
differentiate don't know whole lotta
nothin Oh what is this that's probably
the exit or something I'm dead pounded
my nightmares
okay well Akram's
enthusiast backrooms resident I don't
know
I'll get it okay so that is three scary
games depending of course if the first
game actually recorded properly which it
maybe did maybe did not I have no idea
but thank you everybody so much for
watching check out the other scary games
I've got listed in the description below
and if you've got other scary game
recommendations let me know in the
comments thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always see you
[Music]